taiwanese tech giant tsmc warns an
invasion of the island would render its
factory inoperable devastating global
supply
tensions are rising ahead of a potential
visit to taiwan by u.s house speaker
nancy pelosi and the growing chip
shortage continues last week taiwan said
its key position in making
semiconductors won't be shaken in
response to the u.s passing a law to
subsidize its domestic semiconductor
industry in an effort it says to compete
globally europe wants to ramp up
production germany's been trying to
clinch a deal for a plant from tsmc the
biggest player the company's factories
in taiwan are running it full capacity
to alleviate the
shortages over to our studio in taipei
where zach lee is standing by
here in germany uh and in europe some
politicians are warning of a lack of
semiconductors due to the tensions in
taiwan do people in taipei have the same
concerns
well as you mentioned people here do
have concerns about a shortage of trips
but this is not because of the tensions
in the region for sure an attack by
china will cut off essential
technological goods and human capital
but this is obviously not something most
of people here are concerned about local
people here are very used to china's
threats all the tensions between china
and taiwan all the tensions between the
u.s and china
in fact what has been discussed more is
the chiefs and science act passed in the
u.s last week the act is a plan to
increase the amount of microstrips in
the u.s there has been taiwan worried
about its key position in making
semiconductors as we all know taiwan
plays an important role in global
supplier of semiconductors it dominates
the worst production of semiconductors
to response the auto response to the
chips act in the u.s the taiwanese
authorities also tried to show their
confidence in its semiconductor
production yes made a statement
regarding the chips act in the u.s
saying that it could help taiwanese
chipmakers by providing them subsidies
to build their manufacturing facility in
the u.s
um zach can i just ask you how you see
this story developing considering the
importance of the local semiconductor
industry to the world um and and
all these different changes and
challenges that are facing the industry
right now
yeah as i mentioned taiwan has tsmc
which is the largest shoemaker in asia
it makes more than half of the chips in
the world in our daily life many of our
high-tech products have high quality
chips inside for instance you have an
iphone in your pocket and also a laptop
for desktop those all need chips inside
and chips are so essential component
of electronic devices it's like it's
like a brand of electronics enabling
technology is critical to global
economic growth as well as national
security and the country's global
competitiveness and this is why taiwan's
manufacturer industry is very important
for the world
okay it's going to be very interesting
to see how this one plays out lots of
companies and
countries involved
and uh the competition is going to
remain fierce i'm sure exactly for us
there in taipei thank you
thank you